o sea quien no mayoría han comenzado las
protestas a favor y en contra del aborto
como podéis ver y es que estamos viendo
las dos posiciones una clara un claro
ejemplo de esa brecha profunda social
que divide a esta población a pesar de
que el 67 por ciento de los
estadounidenses está en contra de la
decisión del tribunal supremo- también
hay mucha gente que están a favor de esa
decisión estamos en un estado demócrata
nueva york es uno de los 16 estados de
este país que permitirá que se prepara
para recibir una avalancha de mujeres
que viven en los estados republicanos y
que buscarán estados como estos para
poder interrumpir su embarazo para que
se hagan una idea en este país hay 36
millones de mujeres en edad reproductiva
que viven en estados republicanos y que
no van a poder tener acceso al aborto
ahora otra cuestión que preocupa y mucho
uno de los jueces conservadores del
tribunal supremo- precisamente uno de
los jueces elegidos por el presidente en
donald trump ha sugerido que se revisen
bien las leyes las sentencias que
permiten el uso de anticonceptivos y el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
algo que preocupa mucho a la población y
que llega justo un día antes de que
mañana mismo comiencen las celebraciones
en gran parte del mundo por el orgullo